[Musique]
c'est tous les cas plus là c'est
ruralité aussi n a pas mieux
quant au rôle qui le titre ucar un
morceau de mayotte
oui comme on enchaînera farina d'or ya
beaucoup de papas mais non non non et
non madame farine ça pour moi les
bateaux et gâteau c'est une passion il a
compliqué aussi je fais des confitures
pour te manges papariga longtemps
longtemps longtemps ce chapitre i say
les abeilles avec mon ami bois et ses
biens et les configurations fait boire à
dax et j'ai le temps rien ça on fait
travailler un petit peu les promoteurs
locaux et ça nous fait plaisir les prix
sont intéressants et bien voilà ça fait
une petite sortie de la même si je suis
pas trop simples terminaux haut de gamme
et là c'est intéressant
oui c'est les vacances sont appropriés
[Rires]
dordain
ils comprennent à calan que c'est un
plant au soleil quand vous êtes au dos
offrant ici ce n'est que des bonnes hier
ce en tennis le team yade au géranium et
salaires après la basse et plantes
massif de ben voilà c'est un euro 3
euros 2,50 d'euros à plusieurs reprises
a préparé un rouge en pourparlers
présentés
c'est ça oui oui beaucoup de soutien
voilà c'est bon on vient au 5e rang là
on me parlait là pour payer en état des
voies la sanaga fait en 2007
[Musique]